Turquía ha confirmado este lunes por la
mañana la detención de la supuesta
autora del atentado Ayer por la tarde en
la calle de iscitlán en Estambul en el
centro neurológico de compras y de paseo
de la ciudad del bósforo por este
atentado por esta explosión que ocurrió
a las 4 de la tarde hora turca murieron
seis personas y 81 resultaron heridas
dos de las cuales están en estado muy
crítico y se espera que en los próximos
horas puedan ser o recuperadas o también
puedan sumarse a la cifra de Muertos
según ha explicado el ministro de
interior Turco la presunta autora de
este atentado es una ciudadana Siria que
pertenece a la guerrilla kurdo turca del
PK esta guerrilla llevan guerra en
contra del Estado Turco desde la década
de los 80 en una guerra que ha muerto
cerca de 40.000 personas tanto a manos
de operaciones militares del ejército
Turco como también de la guerrilla curvo
turca que es considerada terrorista
tanto por Turquía como también por la
Unión Europea y los Estados Unidos de
hecho el ministro Turco ha explicado que
no acepta Turquía las cuando las
ciencias y el pésame de Estados Unidos
después de este atentado y no lo hace
porque según Turquía Estados Unidos es
responsable de haber ayudado a esta
guerrilla curro turca del pkk en su
variante sirialas yepegué en la guerra
que Estados Unidos libro durante
2014-2015 2016 en contra del estado
islámico en el norte de Siria